[Music]
[Applause]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was I like to remind
voters that I voted for Ted Cruz said
the Keystone pipeline Hillary Clinton
said the immigration reform bill Bernie
Sanders said the Louisiana Purchase I'll
get I'll get nominated for an Oscar once
the Academy stops ignoring Michael B
Jordan said black people Eva Longoria
said brown people Steven Seagal said
terrible actors in yesterday's Michigan
primaries I was hoping to get John
Kasich said a respectable number of
Delegates Ted Cruz said the support of
the evangelical voters Marco Rubio said
a participation trophy my dream getaway
is Neil Patrick Harris said New York at
Christmastime Jennifer Garner said Paris
in the spring Donald Trump said
Mississippi before the civil war
yeah I won't ratify President Obama's
Supreme Court nominee because John
McCain said it's not appropriate to a
point in an election year Paul Ryan said
he won't nominate someone conservative
enough Mitch McConnell said my shell
flipped over and I can't someone get a
stick and help us out when the Downton
Abbey series ended my first thought was
fitty cent said they had plenty of
dramatic plot lines to do another season
Lil Wayne said Lord Merton's
misdiagnosis of pernicious anemia was
almost too convenient to plot device to
have Issa bell mariam plus there was no
way Julian Fellowes would end this
series with Edith's thinking of herself
as a spinster I was so relieved she
ended up with birdie plus Edith finally
getting the wedding of her dreams was
the piece de resistance and Suge Knight
said that [ __ ] me up
every year I go in for my annual
Courtney Cox said checkup Kevin Nealon
said physical Larry King said autopsy
he's fine he just gets one yeah next
year doc yeah thanks doc I'll see you
next year my most challenging role was
an actor was Daniel day-lewis said a
quadriplegic in my left foot Eddie
Redmayne said a transgender woman in the
Danish girl
Vin Diesel said groot because I had to
say I am Groot
but I'm not really grew and finally when
I have trouble falling asleep I Daniel
Radcliffe said read a very dull book
Melissa McCarthy said count sheep Bill
Cosby said drink whatever's left in her
glass
[Applause]
you